scp-682 found itself hurtling through an
unstable dimensional Rift and into some
fresh new hell 682 Rose from the dirt
and mulched beneath its body and found
itself on level 23 of the back rooms
which had the distinguishing
characteristics of being a spherical
planetoid formed from the interlocking
of countless towering trees it was
commonly known as the Petrified garden
and it was the first of many back rooms
levels that took the form of a globe
rather than an infinite maze I know that
it is hard to imagine a spherical world
because in our native reality the planet
Earth is a flat plane with ice walls on
the side
just kidding the Flat Earth model is an
inaccurate and roundly discredited
conception of cosmography without any
empirical evidence to support it could
you imagine if we were peddling this
kind of conspiratorial fiction here in a
YouTube video anyway back to our
regularly scheduled program about an
indestructible lizard traveling through
another dimension that's real nearly all
the tree specimens present on level 23
had equivalent species that were native
to the front rooms AKA are reality there
were birch trees Cedars redwoods White
Oaks and many more common types
intertwined with trees that were either
long extinct or never before seen on
Earth 2682 a tree was a tree but then
again the ketter class SCP wasn't known
for having a deep and abiding respect
for nature right now what was flashing
through its reptilian head was a need to
inflict violence preferably on the old
Wanderer that warped scp-682 to level 23
but really any entity that crossed its
path was liable to get a taste of the
old Ma and Claw thankfully the back
rooms had a habit of deploying wave
after wave of bizarre creatures from who
knows where not more than a couple
levels ago 682 had been faced with a
veritable Army of these backrooms
entities and came out of the fight
Victoria
by this point the hard to destroy
reptile was well acquainted with death
rats death moths clumps smilers and
Hounds all of which were no doubt
lurking somewhere in the Woodwork of
level 23. you can't run you can hide but
I will find you and destroy you
682 was on the hunt once again walking
through the entangled mess of trees like
an Unstoppable engine of Rage it had
certainly been some time since 682 had
encountered an entirely new entity
though it wasn't exactly clamoring for a
new lore expansion since 682 was a being
that despised all forms of life and
wanted to destroy it the reptile had the
Outlook of the less entities that were
present throughout the back rooms the
better so when the Volpe appeared before
682 the anomalous monster was less than
thrilled but I'll bet that you viewers
at home are excited to get to know a
brand new backrooms entity after such a
long wait so why don't we give you the
Carfax
um car fox fox facts we're going to tell
you about the Volpe now which no matter
how it appears to the untrained eye is
not in fact a fox the volpe's entity
number is 119 and its name comes from
the Corsican word for fox but I must
once again clarify this entity is not
actually a fox the easiest way is to
distinguish a Volpe from its more
well-known counterpart in the front
rooms are the abnormally elongated snout
and the secondary tail volpes have been
known to dwell almost exclusively in
levels of the back rooms that display
forest-like characteristics which one
could imagine would be very few of them
but genuinely who knows at this point
there could be an infinite number of
infinite forests infinitely scattered
across infinite layers of the back rooms
and if that were to be the case there
would be an infinite number of volpes in
all of them an entity 119 and its
natural habitat will dwell within a
Subterranean Den where the Volpe digs
itself in order to provide shelter and
protect itself from low temperatures
these dens can be unusually elaborate
and may comprise multiple branching
tunnels and security measures such as a
collection of Twigs that can alert the
Volpe to Intruders when they are
Disturbed this complexity is somewhat
warranted because the Volcan stores a
plentiful stash of food deep within the
den making it very unlikely for them to
go hungry these volpes are rather clever
aren't they perhaps they are but not
quite clever enough to avoid being
effortlessly crushed by a cp682 as it
brought its two front claws down on top
of the entity better luck next time
entity 119 not that there will be a next
time
scp-682 continued to move along the
surface of the planetoid and eventually
entered into a cavern created by the
intertwining Roots delving beneath level
23's forested crust the reptile found
itself inside of a Glow Room an
underground chamber lit by the
bioluminescence of glow worm-like
entities which had been given the name
Gardner's saris as their name would
imply these creatures constantly made
noises that sounded vaguely like the
word sorry these pitiful worms crawled
around the glowing fungi and smaller
Flora making their signature noises and
scp-682 she was absolutely not sorry to
messlessly devour every one of The
Gardener's saris the room was much
darker with the absence of The
Gardener's sarees but only temporarily
so as scp-682 was able to take on the
bioluminescent glow of its own and light
its way deeper beneath the surface of
level 23. it soon entered an area of
ancient ruins that seemed man-made yet
overgrown with moss and long abandoned
scp-682 had seen sparing evidence
throughout the back rooms of abandoned
human civilizations but the ruins of
level 23 were closer in appearance to
the structures built by the people of
682's native reality they were similar
to some of the great wonders of the
world but with fundamental differences
for example a number of new replicas of
the Pyramids of Giza deviated in shape
Enough From The Originals to be arranged
in a spherical formation the other
buildings found within this area of
level 23 had obvious counterparts but
none of the architecture represented
modern design Trends the most advanced
buildings were equivalent to buildings
in the front rooms constructed in and
before 1000 A.D in and among the ancient
ruins could be found a large variety of
artifacts all of which seemed equally to
be shoddy knockoffs of relics from the
front rooms
scp-682 stepped across the fragile
Pottery in clay Idols quietly satisfied
at the sight of many telltale signs of
civilizational collapse and the utter
lack of living humans there were a few
clumps fiddling around in the rubble but
682 didn't let them get away with
existing in its presence you Dreadful
rejects can return but not Jerry how
disgusting I miss Jerry
scp-682's thoughts turned to its lost
companion entity 7 the blue Hyacinth
Macaw had been the only tolerable
presence that 682 had known within the
back rooms and sadly in the hard to
destroy reptile's entire existence this
hateful and terrific being had never
understood the meaning of love and
compassion until Jerry had appeared to
it it was possible that they would never
meet again and this somber realization
weighed heavily on 682's mind the big
lizard continued through the glow room
and noticed an unusual plaque scrawled
in rough Latin while 682 was not an Avid
Reader its adaptive capabilities allowed
it to translate the message that was
left behind by whatever beings
previously inhabited level 23. it read
we dedicate this great sphere of Giza to
the great Gardener in hopes of
forgiveness for the great wrong we have
committed already our purple eyes have
turned green we have started to return
to the Earth forgotten and overgrown our
only hope is that alone and petrified we
will not disappear as Architects of a
failed project the first sentence was
apparently a clear reference to the
spherical Great Pyramid that 682 had
come across earlier but the significance
of the rest remained a mystery however
these failed Architects were there was
no trace of them left on this planetoid
682 didn't warn them of course and it
felt almost content to know that
whatever Grand project they had in store
had crumbled leaving their ruins
occupied by the likes of clumps it
served them right for existing for
attempting to create something their
sadness was proof enough that they'd
learned their lesson and had long since
faded into The Ether maybe that's all
the back rooms was in the end a series
of failed attempts at building worlds
that would ultimately be forgotten when
time and people moved on to bigger and
better projects
scp-682 mused on these thoughts as it
proceeded down into the very core of
level 23. to its surprise aside of
remarkable Beauty awaited the reptile
within their countless Roots found and
embraced each other surrounding the
gravity-locked orb of luminescent water
an Apparent Source of light nutrients
and ultimately life for The Greenery of
level 23. this was the heart of the
level and it was fittingly known as the
heart of water 682 stared for a long
time at the heart of water and it wasn't
really sure why naturally occurring
wonders like this held little appeal to
the reptile but somehow this one was
different perhaps it was because at this
moment
scp-682 truly realized how far it had
come from its containment cell at site
19. it had endured every hardship the
back rooms had thrown its way and now it
was looking upon the heart of water an
object that it could never have fathomed
existing and could never have reached
until it truly became free and
uninhibited no longer subject to the
whims of the foundation then the most
unusual thing happened to scp-682 a
function of its physiology that was so
rarely seen or utilized
scp-682 shed a single tier it flowed
Down The Reptilian creature snout and
then arrested by the gravitational pull
of the heart of water floated away and
vanished into the liquid mass this was a
private moment for 682 that not even
Jerry was here to see and yet the fall
of this tear may have solidified a
change in 682 it was a mixed feeling of
Independence and Detachment for most of
its journey through the back rooms
scp-682 had felt an urge to completely
clear the abyss and show no mercy to
every entity that existed within it
whether it manifested as determination
or spite that urge had been the
overriding feeling that had driven
scp-682 to progress through every level
of the back room's in sequential order
but these new feelings made it realize
that even that would be playing into the
hands of the back rooms
scp-682 once thought that the back rooms
were cold and in different place like an
endless universe that arbitrarily
created and destroyed all the beings
that existed in it without purpose or
reason but that was not the case and in
fact it seemed more likely that the
complete opposite was true the back
rooms was imbued by its creators with so
much obvious intention that it was
practically a sentient being the back
rooms was heavily invested in taking
itself seriously and revering every
detail that made each level distinctive
and giving every entity and Hazards a
specific method of ruining the
experience of all Wanderers that passed
through
scp-682 could now see the back rooms for
what it actually was a desperate
pathetic thing clawing for attention but
forever doomed to be obscure and unloved
it was even sadder than an indifferent
Universe because it was a constructed
universe that had no greater meaning
than to be acknowledged for simply being
something where nothing once was it
could even be said that the words on the
plaque of the Glow Room in level 23 were
the ultimate admission of hopelessness
and that there was nothing waiting for
SCP 682 or any other Wanderer but the
similar statements of failed Architects
all the way down and that was to saying
nothing of all the once ambitious Works
within the back rooms that had been
erased by happenstance who could even
say that the numbers that correspond to
backrooms levels that scp-682 had
already traversed were even the correct
ones there could potentially be one or
more entirely different numerical
sequences to the levels that were
equally as true to the ones who labeled
them as such if the back rooms didn't
want to be known to be documented to be
expanded upon I doubt that such rigid
assignments of numbers would have been
acceptable by its creators it wasn't
realizing all of this that 682
remembered the elderly explorer that had
flung him into level 23 while it was
true that things hadn't gone the
reptile's way in that encounter it was
questionable who the real winner was
when it was clear that the man had
dedicated the best years of his life to
researching and wandering the back rooms
sure he had mastered some neat parlor
tricks with the magical items native to
this reality but to be a master of the
back rooms was no better than 682
declaring itself Master of the acid tank
in its prior containment cell that
elderly man with the trinkets could keep
his hollow Victory because 682 would
still be alive and kicking when that
human's bones were nothing more than set
dressing left behind and some heretofore
untouched level of the back rooms his
fate would be the same as the rest of
the back rooms eventually a joke with no
real setup and punchline forgotten to
attempt to complete or destroy or
uncover the Mysteries behind the back
rooms was exactly what the loathsome
cluster of disjointed Concepts wanted
and 682 was done with giving this
liminal nightmare the satisfaction
sometimes the only way to win a game is
not to play the game at all and that was
precisely how
scp-682 would approach the back rooms
from here on out maybe it would be
forever or maybe it would be sent home
at any moment but caring about the
outcome either way was a waste of
precious brain power there was only one
way to deal with the desperate neediness
of the back rooms and that was embracing
and becoming internally the cold
indifferent universe that it could never
be and that was now what scp-682 would
be enlightened and fully detached from
this reality it Strode out of the heart
of water and into another Glow Room only
to find an outpost of major explorers
group waiting for it let's try something
new
scp-682 easily broke down the door and
found itself surrounded by panicked
humans many of them were wielding pump
action squirt guns and had begun
spraying 682 with what seemed to be
almond flavored water 682 didn't react
to these attacks at all and slowly
wandered towards the humans with no
particular urgency pod in my intrusion
682 said grinning with much politeness
as it could muster do any of you fine
people know the way back to level nine
the humans shuddered Unsure how to
answer they stood in their silence until
one brave soul came forth and spoke to
scp-682 there's a Gateway inside this
Outpost that can take you to the next
level said the Explorer but it appears
to be one way since whatever was on the
other side appears to no longer exist
what do you mean it no longer exists
682 asked trying against its better
judgment to make sense of the
circumstances the Explorer nodded and
went on seemingly motivated by fear we
mean it's no longer part of any current
Archive of backrooms related phenomenon
and its name will likely be a race soon
not that having the name would provide
any consolation after all there's still
no telling what is on the other side and
if it was ever what the explorers who
reported on it claimed it was now this
was an unsettling development 682 had
only just started to come to terms with
the instability of reality in the back
rooms and the notion that a level could
be totally wiped from existence and
leave behind a gateway to absolutely
nowhere was chilling even to the
immortal lizard what would happen to 682
if the reptile stepped through the
Gateway would it find itself in the
place that the Gateway was once and
still is connected to or would it simply
disappear into the void as if it were
never there at all because this was the
back rooms there was always a third
option too as well as countless others
that find all logic so now the question
facing scp-682 was to step into the
unknown or to remain here in level 23
with the major explorers group it was a
difficult decision to say the least the
humans looked on as scp-682 carefully
weighed its options eventually the
reptile opened its mouth to speak on the
matter I'll give it some thought 682
said you have been very helpful for a
disgusting human so for the time being I
will permit you to continue your
meaningless existence and I guess that
includes the rest of your Outpost uh oh
that's um well thank you
um yeah thank you the human stammered
682 turned and began to walk towards the
heart of water it intended to take its
time with its Choice since progress
through the levels of the back rooms was
no longer something that the reptile
would be pursuing with Reckless abandon
it heavily considered going back on its
words and slaughtering all the members
of the major explorers group in this
Outpost as it had done in all the other
outposts but it was plain to see that a
human trapped in the back rooms barely
qualified as living because nothing
could be worse than being permanently
stuck in the torturous Abyss 682 had no
idea whether pure Spike towards them was
what made sparing their lives so
compelling or something else had
motivated that decision but regardless
the hard to destroy reptile did not
destroy the humans of level 23. as it
exited the base the brave human that had
spoken to it called out wait lizard I
have to know what are you 682 stopped
and stared at the human it's just we
need to catalog you I've never seen
anything else in the back rooms like you
682 breathed out it sounded almost like
a surrender I am entity six eight two
after those words left its jaws 682
wandered away from the human until it
was once again sitting by the heart of
water he didn't think about the choice
or the Gateway immediately for now
entity 682 was peacefully reminiscing
back to the quality time it had spent
with entity 7 Jerry in this pointless
and nonsensical Place known as the back
rooms they would meet again that was the
one thing 682 could be sure of somehow
some way they would meet again an
indeterminate amount of time later over
24 levels away from the reptile in the
front rooms the reality which it had no
clipped out of so many days and weeks
ago the researchers of the SCP
Foundation had gathered together and
were celebrating an unforeseen event
almost all of them had long since given
up hope that it could ever happen and
yet here they were standing before the
o5 council and all the illustrious
scientists and soldiers that had worked
to make this day a reality everyone
watched in total amazement as the heads
of the foundation declared the cutter
class
scp-682 hard to destroy reptile
permanently neutralized want an anomaly
of your own check out scpswag.com for
high quality SCP merch now go check out
could scp-682 be contained in the back
rooms and scp-682 Slaughters through the
back rooms for more of 682's journey
through the back rooms